guys we just got out of Black Panther we
got out of Black Panthers just now I'm
early screaming nan the crowd didn't
clap everyone just hated this movie I'm
sure you can tell it it's probably not
gonna be a good movie but I think we can
all agree that Martin Freeman and Andy
Serkis really really stole the [ __ ]
really did is really their movie
dominantly African American movie we're
gonna do our reasons to see and reasons
not to see this it's our review format
we've been reintroducing again onto the
channel just so we have a way of
breaking down the film and an easier
format for us and for you to get our
point of view on things fun so let's get
into this shall we and heads up we're
gonna be doing a spoiler review for this
movie by the time it's actually released
give some people time to watch it to
them because we don't want to be those
guys who ruin everything even though
they'll be people who'll be doing that
already
before it's even yeah we should just do
that and then the non spoiler all right
so reason to see number one would have
to be obviously chadwick boseman he is
amazing in this film yeah he's not
necessarily the flashiest performance
but he really does Italy yeah he really
does lead this film yeah cuz this story
is about as you can pick up from the
trailers it's about two chala becoming
king of Wakanda and he's learning his
position on being a king there's also a
very specific mission that takes place
in this film that I don't want to give
away because they don't really make it
clear in the trailers through this whole
journey to Charlotte does have some
crazy learning lessons he has to go
through and he has a lot of scenes where
he's super subtle and then scenes where
he's very emotional
he's got has a wide range of emotions
and pulls off every scene perfectly his
interaction with the whole cast is great
loved it he loved you get to see him as
a king as a warrior as the member of a
family as a human as a superhuman like
he he has so many different facets to
his performance especially for the
origin story quality I mean he's got to
learn not only how to be a leader in
terms of traditions but also really
embody and confront the difficult parts
that taking up leadership means and
confronting the poor leadership
decisions of the past like there's a lot
of development for that character and he
rocks it reason to see number two
Michael B Jordan so Michael B Jordan as
advertising the trailer plays Eric hill
monger boy oh boy has the MCU given us
easily in my personal opinion the best
villain yeah we've ever gotten it's like
Michael Keaton in spider-man homecoming
I was like okay he's probably the best
this is a movie that you walk out of and
you're like oh yeah
no doubt about it that was the greatest
villain yeah this one works on multiple
level yes you know it's crazy to have an
origin movie of Black Panther and then
equally have a movie that has such a
strong three-dimensional villain with a
crazy backstory and really elevated by
Michael B Jordans performance it is a
performance that I connect it with
without giving anything away it was
weird cuz he's the villain of the movie
yet he was the one who probably got me
the most emotional in the movie - you
really understand where he comes from
and in his struggle is on multiple
levels you know cuz there's a personal
element to his Vendetta there's a global
element there's like a cultural element
like you really get to understand this
guy's philosophies inside and out and he
becomes really compelling villain
because of that because you get why he's
fighting and the faceoff you know in
terms of just the weight of him versus
T'Challa is really beautiful in a lot of
ways this is his movie - yeah yeah yeah
I mean because they're at the core of a
philosophical debate that will affect
what Conda yeah and also this is the
sexiest Michael B Jordan has ever been
yeah like I was watching it man I don't
know like yeah this guy's freaking sexy
I'd let my girl Carrie but he also just
owns the room like reason to see number
three Lupita Nyong'o and deny deny deny
career in a career well on this movie
being a film that really celebrates
African culture in a lot of ways and has
a lot of black pride which is one of the
best elements of this movie
[Music]
[Music]
the others side to this film is there's
a lot of female empowerment in this film
and these two characters they're
different characters you know it's like
they're both badass with condo warrior
woman yeah they are one Lupita Nyong'o
is more of the love interest character
when she's the more of the individual
whereas Danai gurira his character is
very loyal so yeah
state to the throne you know her
performance Lupita's she's that woman
who's stubborn but you see why you want
her to be with T'Challa and their
chemistry on-screen together is great
their dialogue is awesome and then deny
the definition of a badass woman so
tough and so awesome like I like that
actress on the walking dead I think
she's I love who were here thank you so
much cooler hearing she had to learn a
whole new art form with the spear that
she uses in this film and man did she
know how to wield that thing dude that
was a crazy ass work she was doing she
is tough she is intimidating and she's a
she's a but she's not just that - she's
someone who's very multi-layered and has
a big heart both of these characters
represents strength realized and it's
also just super fun to get to watch them
all work together yeah and you know go
on I don't know I'm called a mission but
you know they got a couple go kick some
ass together you know it really does
kind of share the mic in a way that
isn't in your face and isn't you know
distracting it's just awesome reason to
see number four latisha right the
challahs sister in this movie didn't
know much about this character before
watching it all I heard was we watch
this with our friend Andrew Gordon and
he said I hear that she is like a smart
as Tony Stark and I'm like hmm okay and
I watch the film and she is so cool she
is like head Tony Stark she is that cue
in terms of her intelligence level and
ability to invent and create on a
technological advanced level beyond that
she is so funny she's the funniest one
in the movie yeah yeah yeah she brings a
lot of heart and and yeah a lot of the
good humor to things yeah she is really
history yeah yeah
what side of the road is robust sick
just come down yeah she has a very
delightful performance and it's truly
blared as well so glad you don't really
see a lot of her in the trailers and
stuff you get like brief moments I think
she's a big surprise to that I hope more
people will start talking about actually
well that was the thing leading up to
this film she was one of the names I've
heard the most and and one of the
characters I knew the least about and
that was a real treat here again she is
so important and she gets to do some
pretty awesome stuff everybody else even
though it is black panther and it is two
challahs movie there is a lot of
ensemble going on yeah which moves on to
our next reason to see reason to see
number five the whole supporting gas
pretty much everyone's good in this film
I mean the characters that we took time
to give a specific reason for is because
they're central they share a lot of
screen time but there's other supporting
players in this film that got moments of
shine too it's you know when you see a
large ensemble on screen like oh I'm
looking at Forest Whitaker in the poster
Daniel Kaluga Angela Bassett Martin
Martin Freeman Andy Serkis
a lot of times you see a bunch of big
players you usually walk out of the film
like that going I really wish I used
this person more I wish to use this for
some more wish you did something more
with this character everyone hmm
everyone gets a chance to shine
Martin Freeman returns every Ross he's
used to great effect in this film don't
want to give anything about its Ross yet
Daniel kahlúa don't even remember seeing
him in the trailers really so I thought
he was gonna be like oh one of those
actors that I would wish he did more
yeah and he plays a very different
character than the rest it's a different
performance than what I've ever seen
Daniel Kalia do either and he's really
good in the film he is early in the
movie too yeah he's got a pretty
emotional one yeah and sterling K Brown
who I didn't realize was in this video
it's sterling K Brown another great
performance that's what he does man who
shows up touches you and then leaves the
Forest Whitaker I immediately flashed to
the fact that he was in rogue one I
didn't really he's here for him he's
playing this guy right now yeah but he
would have been better yeah I thought he
had a great effect and there were subtle
moments like I can think it was very
specific shots or I was like that was a
powerful look that he gave then does a
lot of meanings gravitas Smith
his big purple robes and all Woodson
Duke plays a pretty notable comic book
character in this film he he's a
charming guy yeah he steals the scenes
that he's in one performance that really
paid off Andy Serkis is cloth oh dude
he's so much fun to watch because we
haven't seen cloth since age of Ultron
and usually when a character makes like
a little cameo they come back within a
year of the MCU films in a few years and
he comes back and making them way more
to do with this yeah yeah yeah he's a
he's a standout in the film pretty sure
it's a scoundrel and you can tell he's
having a blast and it totally works and
he does bring a splash of you know humor
yeah to pretty much every scene he's
arguably the most animated character out
of everyone in this film yeah but he
does it in a way where I just believe it
yeah there's something's great to see
without mocap it is it is just to be
able to drink in and appreciate the
character work that that guy is capable
of because arguably sure just got in his
own category on our list here I feel
like yeah they got more screen time you
know reason to see number six the
writing and directing this film kind of
just throws you into it right away and
it's not long after where you're like
this is a very different Marvel film
this is a world exploration of Wakanda
that all really pays off it's like
celebrates like African culture
extrapolates it yes exactly and it
addresses a whole bunch of issues about
war and how black people are treated a
lot of themes about leadership and what
it was so fascinating to me by the time
this movie all wrapped up it doesn't
ever feel over or bombarded too much
information or too much stuff they're
trying to all throw into one movie it's
a giant ensemble everyone's treated
great in this film and all the themes
are really communicated the themes are
all spread out throughout the way the
plot is unfolding and that's what was
really cool though the themes are always
reflective in the plot at hand and the
way the plots executed is done super
well it kept going places I wasn't
expecting it to go even though it starts
off pretty strong and like we're
throwing you into this it also is a
build-up film the pacing is great while
it deals with a lot
big world political issues that deals a
lot with super personal real things -
the personal stuff within each of these
characters is just as relevant and just
as relatable and that's what makes it
feel personal for such a epic scope of a
film
it feels very personal yeah and I got a
plot a movie that I'll start thinking
something and then the movie 10 minutes
later will start addressing yeah because
so many of those little political or
even personal points are things were
they crossed my mind and then the movie
started to talk about them and I do got
a watch especially in the writing for
that especially in the choice to go
after some of those themes because this
is an opportunity of a movie kind of
jump into stuff in familiar territory
and then the movie blossoms outwards and
they're the way in which they work their
themes into everything because there is
all the Marvel action and stuff that you
want they have the conversation in this
movie like what Conda is a stronghold
what does that mean like what is our
relationship to the rest of the world
and they don't shy away from those and
and kill mongers motivations are very
much built out of abandonment and out of
the atrocities that he's seen across the
world and the sort of unfairness of it
all and the movie just confronts a lot
of things even even for DES chala it's
not just like a standard origin story
no really gotta learn lessons that we
haven't seen any other MCU character
learning yeah it's not just about the
power and the mantle and you know like
being authentic on it really is about
finding what's right
that adds such a weight to everything
yeah because every major character is
forced to confront that it's yeah and in
terms of the action too well and there's
an argument to be made of what are the
best shot action sequences in any of the
Marvel films other than Winter Soldier
this is the one Marvel film that I
really felt a super intensity this was a
suspenseful film it's not meaningful act
yes every time there was an action scene
it was gripping it was more than just
cool were flowing the Gooding an action
scene it was intense and significant to
what was at stake in the moment not
every action scene is the same you
actually get different types of set
pieces and different types of action
sequences in here every single time one
of those was going on I was really
gripped by the intensity of the
situation yeah it's cool that's kind of
secondary to what's really at hand
everything else is on a different plane
and has a different like political
weight to it I guess in terms of just
who's fighting and why as far as an
action movie goes it does a great job of
effortlessly working it in reason to see
number seven visual effects and design
this movie has a really cool palette to
it in terms of just the color like it's
the most colorful Marvel movie in a
completely different way it's not
spandex and everything and it's not 80s
yeah you know this is really mired in
culture and I really appreciate this
movie before and it makes it all the
more distinct because of that and
everything is filtered through that
their technology is vetted through that
the color choices are filter costume
design costume designs are really
amazing to look at you know and there's
a wide variety and it's the most
impressive arguably to me of all these
because it's the least familiar to me
the most impressive aesthetic of it is
when it's honoring the African culture
the cinematography in this film I think
this is one of the better looking MCU
films I think there's a distinct look to
it oftentimes in the MCU films they kind
of feel like they're shot by the same
people hood yeah you know that's like
yeah there's some uniformity yeah here
it doesn't feel that way like there's
specific types of color tints and
cinematography and set designs it's the
imagery itself I was gripped by this
film when just looking at it cuz it just
felt I would kind of forget I'm watching
a Marvel film it has its own vibe and
the cinematography and the designs all
kind of come together to accentuate that
if there were moments where other MCU
things were referenced I was never
really thinking about I know it wasn't
even real aware yeah it just wasn't in
my mind all that was in my mind was this
movie and each passing moment and I feel
like the way they captured it and the
way they designed it all like it really
drinks in the design so you really get
to experience the world of Wakanda as it
unfolds in front of you you know instead
of having to have somebody give you like
a massive info-dump here and there and a
little bit of South Korea
reason to see number eight the music
Ludwig goranson of childish gambino Fame
see this MCU film has done something
magical what are the two biggest
complaints you can get about a Marvel
film its villain and the music it
doesn't really stand out the music in
this film yeah yeah yeah yes good yeah
good I remember watching scenes and
going this is a freaking great music in
this it was the kind of music I kind of
wish some of the trailers had it was the
exact kind of music that we would say I
wish the trailers were using this so
much of it is so percussive and there
are some modern touches on it every now
and again when it's appropriate like you
know a synth beat will drop in it
depends where they are in the movies
yeah if they're in Wakanda it's
primarily has like that African tribe
type of music yeah there's a lot of
percussive and a lot of like
vocalization based stuff yeah it's got a
wide variety and without getting up in
your face about it I thought it was
really a distinctive part of the movies
DNA now it's the one MCU there I'm like
I would get the album yeah even with
Kendrick Lamar's I think it's one of the
other ones too cuz I think that's the
one that has like Vince staples or
something oh yeah everything again comes
together in a really nice way and it's
yeah it's nice to have a Marvel movie
where you can point to it and go the
music is memorable too yeah because I
usually only just remember The Avengers
theme yes because we've heard a bunch of
reasons not to see cuz you're a Marvel
fan boy who wants his Marvel movies to
be the exact way Marvel usually does
their movies yeah so there's no real
reasons not to see his movie not enough
white people I might have been I feel
underrepresented I might have had like a
minor nitpick here or there but overall
I really didn't the reason why we're
making this like joke reason not to is
because it is so different than the
other Marvel films especially after last
year you got like three Marvel comedies
in a row yeah and then this one brings
it back to more like Winter Soldier or
worse like this is a pretty serious
movie yeah the serious intense film and
this film owed nothing to the 1980s yeah
cuz every film last year own something
to the 1980 it's not jam-packed with
other Marvel character references it's
not jam-packed
being aware of the bigger universe it's
not about setting up other like a Paris
and infinity war the fact that it's just
a true standalone origin film that takes
itself really serious and when there's
humor it's the right amount of humor I
think people who just love going to
these movies really want to show up for
the fun really want to show up for that
and this is a different type of fun this
is a type of fun where you if you miss a
piece of information it'll affect the
way the movie feels for you well this
movie also has some stuff on its mind
that is weighty and that has force you
element and important there's a little
bit think about the world and think
about how we all behave as nations and
stuff like that and think about
abandonment and and other things there's
a lot going on yeah under the hood and
you know I can definitely see a certain
people being like I like my movies fun
especially when you're coming off of
like the last three Marvel movies we had
which are like heartfelt but they're
mainly just fun alright guys well
there's a review of Black Panther I mean
obviously if you were to sum it up since
we can't really find anything wrong with
the movie I don't want to say it's
perfect just yet as we did just come
back from the movie and I find sometimes
by my words when I do like love
something off of a fresh screening I
honestly think that it's a film that
everyone should go check out probably
the most important MCU film I think
we've gotten yeah uses what it is to
address some real life stuff yeah oh no
yeah one more thing I wanted to do I
want to give a shout out to a Delia
Chamberlain Adelia my dear I know you
had foot surgery a month ago you're
going through some pretty harsh times
right now in 2018 and I know sometimes
you get a little bit worried about
opening up to us over at our patreon but
I want to let you know that every time
we get a message from you I love talking
with you I love chatting with you love
here and all the updates in your life
and I'm glad that you're really working
on yourself right now and going out
there and trying new things stay proud
of yourself homegirl because you were
one beautiful soul and I hope you never
lose that all right guys you can
subscribe to the rejects click that
notification value notified every time
one of our videos is up yeah check out
our patreon it's one over there